Most of the animals used at the fair
are rented.
Very few animals are own
and who are carried by their horsemen
or their owners to the celebrations,
which normally
care for them much more than those who are rented.
In the end,
they are mere exploited animals.
These are things,
are they treated like
object and good eh?
We also have many examples of falls
1 horse of 1 charré,
is moving,
another horse comes,
they replace it and continue to work.
We have been documenting this since last year as well.
and say, well,
and this happens habitually,
of course we know that it will continue to happen
because. Um,
this doesn't hold anyone back.
It is 1 image that also unfortunately
is taken as usual.
People already understand it as normal
and this should not be the case.
It should not be taken for granted that they die
animals at the fair in 1 celebration,
is that no, no,
we did not conceive of it.